so what do we have right here well this
is just a this is just a water molecule
and this right over here let's see we
have one two
three carbons in our backbone so this
would be meth
propene we all have single bonds right
here so this is propane let me write
that out this is give myself some space
propane
and then on the number two carbon i have
both a methyl group and a bromo group
and bro bromo comes before methyl in
alphabetical order so i could write this
as
two bromo two
bromo two methyl
two
methyl
propane so that's this molecule that we
have right over here now what we're
going to imagine it's sitting in some
water and i have one water molecule
drawn right over here
let's imagine that we have look we have
this bromine right over here it's pretty
neutral and it's neutral because it has
or it is neutral because it has seven
valence electrons one two or you could
say or it has the charge equivalent it
has one two three four five six and then
it has half of this bond that's composed
of two electrons so that's what's
keeping this neutral right over here
but we do know that bromine well you
know it's it's it's it's not completely
unstable if it were to take an electron
because that would get it to eight
valence electrons we know that it's more
electronegative than carbon which means
that if it's sharing a bond it's more
likely to take the entire bond than
carbon is so let's imagine a scenario
let's imagine a scenario where bromine
takes these two carbons in this bond
right over here and this isn't going to
be a super fast thing that happens
because this molecule right over here
the 2-bromo 2-methyl propane is actually
reasonably stable so i'm not saying this
is going to just happen automatically
it's going to happen super fast but it
could happen and so to show that this
isn't going to be a you know only a
one-way reaction i'll show that it's an
equilibrium so the equilibrium i'll draw
two arrows
like that and so once this happens the
bromine
would turn into a bromide anion so let
me draw it right over here
so the bromide anion so it's going to
have one two three four five six and
then both electrons from that shared
bond
both electrons from that shared bond
it now has a it now has a negative one
charge
now if that happened what would happen
to this leftover to i guess what's now
going to be
this this the the the thing that the
bromine was connected to i guess you
could say
well let's draw that so we have
this carbon our number two carbon
we have ch3 right over there let me go
back to a c h3 and then i had this blue
methyl group so i had this blue methyl
group right here and the way i'm drawing
it it kind of pops out of the page
my best attempt to draw it popping out
of the page
so this is it
popping
out of the page
and now what's its charge going to be
well it just gave up half of this bond
the equivalent of of an electron's
charge so it just gave up you could kind
of think of it as giving up an electron
so this is going to have a positive
charge
this is going to have a positive charge
and a positive charged carbon like this
we would call this a carbo cation
so this right over here
is a carbo
carbocation positive charge and the
reason why this is not a crazy thing to
happen is that this is a tertiary carbon
which means it is connected to three
other carbons one two three a tertiary
carbon one way to think about it is that
this this this this positive charge can
kind of be shared with its brothers a
little bit more so tertiary tertiary
carbocation is more stable than a
secondary and definitely more stable
than a primary secondary would be if it
was only connected to two carbons but
this is tertiary so let me write this
down this is a tertiary
carbocation it's
this carbon is connected to three other
carbons that's where the tertiary comes
from so once again
it can happen i'm not saying that this
reaction is just going to go super fast
in that direction that's why we did
these equilibriums
this these equilibrium arrows
now let's bring this oxygen into play so
let's bring
now let's bring this it's not sorry not
the oxygen let's bring this water into
play
so this water as you can imagine the
water is neutral it might seem it seems
pretty reasonable in this state
but it does have a
the oxygen end of the water does have a
partial negative charge we've seen in
the past
we've we've seen in the past
that because oxygen is a lot more
electronegative than the hydrogens that
you have a partial negative side on the
side of the oxygens and you have a
partial positive charge on the side of
the hydrogens on the side of the
hydrogens and so you have this positive
carbocation this has a partially
negative charge so you could imagine
that this this molecule might be
attracted to this nucleus now it's not
going to be super attracted the way that
a hydroxide anion would a hydroxide ion
has a full negative charge this only
just has a little partial negative
charge but it could still be attracted
to something very positive like this so
in this situation the water molecule is
a weak nucleophile
so this is a weak
a weak nucleophile no not as strong as a
hydroxide anion that has a full negative
charge but if it sees something positive
like this and it bumps in the right way
you could imagine that one of these
pairs of this oxygen would then go
one of these pairs on this oxygen would
then go and essentially form a bond with
this carbon making this carbon making
this carbon right over here neutral so
what is that going to look like and this
might happen a little this would happen
faster so i'm not going to do this as an
equilibrium this could happen like
this and let me
let me just copy and paste the bromine
so i don't have to redraw the whole
thing
so
let me copy and let me paste it
so that's our bromine right over there
right there
actually let me erase that little
this little smudge and make sure it
still has a negative charge
so
negative
charge it's a bromide anion now now let
me draw the everything else so i have
this carbon
this carbon let me scroll down a little
bit so i have some space carbon i have
the carbon in the back
ch3 i have the carbon on top
ch3 i have the carbon in front
i have the carbon in front
like that
ch3 and now my oxygen or that i should
say this molecule right over here the
water molecule has attached to the
carbon
so
these two electrons
you could say they've attacked the
carbon they now form a bond with the
carbon
they form now so those these are those
two electrons in this covalent bond and
now let's draw the rest of this so you
have the oxygen
you have these two electrons right over
here these two valence electrons
and then you have
one hydrogen and then another hydrogen
now what is going to be the charge what
is going to be the charge right over
here on the oxygen
well it was it had a partial negative
charge just because it's more
electronegative but it just gave it just
gave the the
essentially half of a bond half of a
pair it's now sharing or it's now
sharing a pair with this carbon so it's
equivalent of giving up one electron's
equivalent of charge so you now say that
this thing right now has a positive a
positive charge so you could imagine you
could imagine maybe another water
molecule comes along
maybe another water molecule comes along
we draw another water molecule right
over here
we're sitting in water so there's plenty
of water molecules
so another water
molecule might come along and say okay
well you know this is this this thing
right over here is positive but this the
oxygen is hogging is is hogging these
bonds a little bit more than the
hydrogens especially now that it's
become positive and so this might give
its pair to a hydrogen proton and then
this hydrogen
and then this bond with the hydrogen
will go entirely entirely to
entirely to the oxygen let me draw that
in a different color
so this bond this bond right over here
goes entirely it goes entirely to the
oxygen electronegativity means if
there's a this is more electronegative
than that then if a bond breaks at that
pair is more likely to go to the more
electronegative
the more electronegative molecule
or i should say the more electronegative
atom so what will this look like when
all is said and done
so let's draw an arrow like this so let
me draw my main
my main molecule so i have the carbon
it has bonded to another carbon right up
there it's bonded to another carbon
right over there we have our carbon in
front
we have our carbon in front
just like that
we have the bond with our oxygen
so we have our bond with our oxygen
right over there
so that's our oxygen it had we have this
bond with a hydrogen this bond with a
hydrogen we have this pair and now it
has gained this pair
it has gained this pair that was with
that hydrogen so just like this this is
now neutral it went from being positive
it over here it only had half of this
bond so it's kind of the equivalent of
one electron charge now it has the whole
bond so now has equivalent it has
literally has both electrons so now this
thing is neutral and now this molecule
right over here becomes a hydronium
cation let me draw that so this water so
let me see so that's the two hydrogens
right over there
this is that pair that is on top and now
and now it has sharing it is sharing
this paint this this pair with a
hydrogen essentially with a proton so
with the hydrogen
with this hydrogen
right over here with this hydrogen
right over here and now this will have a
positive charge this is a hydronium this
is a hydronium cation and maybe this
bumps into another water molecule and
does the same thing with it and it just
keeps going on and on and on and of
course we can't we can't forget
we can't forget our bromide anion friend
so there's our bromide anion friend
we've got a negative charge right over
there and so what are we left with
well we are left with well there's a
little bit of there's there's a there's
this hydronium cation has a positive
charge you have this bromide anion and
now what is this molecule now called
well we'll go into more detail in the
future but when you have a hydroxyl
group attached to the carbon backbone it
is an alcohol and so our main backbone
once again has one two three carbons so
that tells us probe but instead of just
saying propane it's propanol
so let's write that down this is probe
proper proton
and some people say just propanol
generally but if we want to be a little
bit particular this is the the hydroxyl
group is attached to the number two
carbon so we would say propone2
proponent two all and of course we still
have this blue methyl group so we could
say two methyl
two
methyl let me make this
methyl propon2 all is what we are left
with
now let's think about what we can name
what we can name this reaction we just
saw
well we've just substituted a bromo
group with a hydroxyl group so i think
it's reasonable to say that this is
going to be a substitution reaction
substitution
and we substituted with a it was a weak
nucleophile but it was a nucleophile
nonetheless so it involved a nucleophile
nucleophile
but this one unlike the sn2 reaction in
the rate determining step and this is
the rate determining step this is the
slowest step of the process everything
else will just kind of kind of start
happening once this thing happens this
thing kind of is an equilibrium this is
the rate determining step only one
reactant is involved in the rate
determining step
one reactant
in
rate determining step
rate
determining step in this in this case it
was the bromo group so you might guess
what we're going to call it it's
substitution involving a nucleophile so
nucleophilic substitution you can
imagine it stands for nucleophilic and
only one reactant is vol is involved in
the rate determining step so this right
over here this whole reaction that we've
now drawn is an
sn1 reaction
we're now going to explore one of the
most fundamental reactions in organic
chemistry
and first let's look at what what what
are the things that are going to react
so over here i have a hydroxide anion it
has a negative one charge and that
negative one charge comes from the fact
that oxygen is neutral if it has six
valence electrons but this has one two
three four five six plus
plus half of this bond with hydrogen so
you could think of that as another
electron or it's sharing it's it's got
half of these two so that's another
electron which gives it a negative one
charge
now this right over here it has one
carbon i guess if you could say in its
backbone so you would use it's it's a
methane and it has a group right over
here consisting of bromine so this is
bromo this is bromomethane
so let's think a little bit about what
might happen under the right conditions
so this hydroxide anion we've already
gone over the fact that you can kind of
view it as having an extra electron
which gives us this negative charge well
if you have a negative charged anion
like this it will be attracted to
positive things and one example of a
positive thing is a nucleus and so in
this reaction we are going to refer to
this
hydroxide anion as the nucleophile
nucleophile
file literally refers to things that
something likes this thing likes it it's
a nucleus lover i guess you could say
and so it might want to it might want to
share maybe a pair of electro a pair of
electrons with a nucleus
now over here i have this bromo group in
the bromo methane
and bromine is quite electronegative it
is more electronegative than carbon so
even in this bond we have two electrons
in this bond right over here bromine is
going to hog the electrons a little bit
more than carbon and also
electronegativity says that if this bond
were to break it's more likely that this
pair the pair that's in this bond is
going to go to the bromine then it's
going to go to the carbon so the way
that this reaction works and it's really
kind of happening in one step and this
is key to the name of this reaction as
we'll see in a second
is that this nucleophile right over here
might say hey let me share i got this
extra charge let me share some of that
charge with a nucleus in this case in
this case the carbon you draw it like
this
in this case the carbon
so it would share this pair which would
form a bond carbon would have half of
the pair oxygen would have half of the
pair so it would share
this pair
it would share this pair with carbon now
if carbon is now sharing half of this
it's getting it's essentially kind of
getting half an elect or it's getting an
electron it doesn't need this electron
which bromine is already hogging a
little bit and so bromine would take
this entire pair back whenever we draw
full arrows like this just normal arrows
that you're used to seeing it's
referring to the action of pairs so this
whole pair is going to bromine this pair
right over here is now going to be
shared with the carbon it's going to
form a bond with the carbon so when we
do both of these steps after both of
these steps it would look like this
it would look like this let me draw my
bromine first which is now going to
become a bromide anion
so
bromine one two three four five six
one two three four five six
and now it gets both of these electrons
both of these electrons from this from
this bond so it has both of those
electrons right over there
now this will have a negative one charge
how do we know that well bromine is posi
is bromine is neutral when it has seven
valence electrons this thing now has
eight so this now has a
that has a negative charge now let's
think let's think about what happens to
all of this business so let me draw my
carbon first
my carbon now let me draw this hydrogen
that's popping out
so this hydrogen that's popping out let
me draw it like that
so that's the bond trying to show that's
popping out of the page
so that's that hydrogen
i just made them different colors so we
can keep track of the different
hydrogens then the hydrogen that's going
into the page
that's that one right over there then
you have this hydrogen that's going up
so that hydrogen right over there and
now the hydroxide anion has bonded to
this carbon now it's it'll be a hydroxyl
group
so
this thing has now bonded so let me draw
the bond and the color of these two
electrons it has now bonded so this
those two electrons now make up this
blur this bond right over here
and now we have our oxygen
but with
one those two these two right over here
these two right over here and then the
bond to the hydrogen now what just
happened here the oxygen is now neutral
y is individual well it has one two
three four and then it has half of this
bond so you could view that as
an electron or the equivalent of an
electron charge and then it has half of
this bond so it has the electron charge
equivalent of six valence electrons
which makes oxygen neutral and now
bromine is negative so one way to think
about is that the negative charge has
been transferred to the bromine in this
reaction
now in this reaction bromine has left
and that's why we call this the leaving
group
we call this right over here the leaving
the leaving group
the leaving group of the reaction this
thing is right over here is the thing
that is going to leave
that is the leaving group
now the other thing that you might find
interesting it looks like kind of this
hydroxide anion some people would even
say attacked this bromo methane the
bromomethane left the hydroxide anion
the hydroxide anti the the bromine left
not the bromo methane left attract the
bromo attacked the bromo bromo methane
the bromine left so in some ways you
would say that there's really two
reactants over here you have the
hydroxide anion and have you have the
bromide anion and this carbon right over
here with the hydrogens this was kind of
the thing that just to somebody
facilitated the reaction that you know
this thing bumped into it and attached
and then this thing left and so in this
context we would call
the carbon with the three hydrogens we
would call this the substrate
the substrate
substrate
now what should we call this reaction
well one way to think about it is we
substitute into this bromo group with a
hydroxyl group so it might make sense to
call this a substitution reaction
substitution has occurred substitution
has occurred now what did we substitute
with well we substituted with a
nucleophile
we substituted
with a nucleophile
and how many reactants were involved in
the rate determining step and i know
that might not make a lot of sense to
you but this had essentially one inter
one determining step this had to want to
bump in the right way and this would
want to have to leave right at the same
time in order for this or roughly the
same time in order for this reaction to
occur so this reactant and this reactant
were involved in figuring out well how
fast is this reaction going to happen
and we're going to see future reactions
where you don't have both react both
reactants involved in the rate
determining step we'll see only one
reactant involved in the rate
determining step but i'll just write
this right over here two
true reactants
in rate determining step
there's a garbage truck outside
i think the garbage truck has left now
safe to resume so as we were saying
there are two reactants involved in the
rate
in the
determining
determining mining step
and so the shorthand for this reaction
is to call it an s n
s
n
2 reaction an sn2 reaction
it's substitution with a nucleophile
where both reactants are involved in the
rate determining step